welcome back to 8701 so in this lecture
we want to talk about asymptotic freedom
about confinement and also the running
of the strength
of the strong force
in the recitation we already talked
about vacuum polarization in qed and how
it relates to qcd
um so here we are just going to remind
ourselves again about what has been
discussed here
so loop contributions in qd they make
the effective charge a function of the
momentum transfer q
so the coupling strength increases with
larger values of q square
so a leading order you find you have to
consider this diagram and you find
that there are the corrections coming
from um
from this kind of from this kind of
diagram
m here is the mass of the particle
involved
in this correction
but as you know in perturbation theory
you have to consider all possible
diagrams and this is being done here
so if you consider those higher order
diagrams you can rewrite
the running of the qed coupling
as the coupling at q square of zero
divided by one minus this contribution
here
great so there's one there's a couple of
things to note um
so there's a one minus a factor here
um and then there's also the definition
or the
you know fixed point of the coupling as
being used as zero q
square so that's possible in qed but
that will not be possible
in qcd because at momentum transfer 0
the coupling is going to be infinite so
it's not well defined and we cannot use
perturbation theory at this at this
value as either
okay good um so in qcd
we have not just one diagram like the
one we just saw before
but we also have to consider the glue
and self-coupling
diagram so we have contributions of this
sort so i spare you from the calculation
but you find um that the cleon
contribution has an opposite effect um
so it's producing some sort of
anti-screening or camouflaging of this
of the color charge and so you find
if you calculate this in a very similar
way as you did just before we
did just before for qed um you find this
kind of correction
so here you have to define
or fix the strength of the coupling at a
specific scale
and you see that you have this
contribution here there's a plus
here but this factor here which is 11
times the number of colors involved
minus two times the number of flavors
involved those numbers are
3 and 6. so since 11
times n is larger than 2 times f
this becomes positive here and so
therefore
the coupling decreases the coupling
decreases with q square
all right since it decreases with q
square
um at very very high q square the
coupling becomes zero
and that's the origin of asymptotic
freedom
in the limit of very large q square
strongly charged particles color charged
particles become very
number free that's also the reason why
at very high
energies we can use qcdr we can
make calculations in qcd using the
feminine calculus or
perturbation theory
in the other direction um if you go to
very low q square
those methods and tools are not possible
anymore
and quarks and clue ones are actually
confined you can
not produce a
non-color thing that states by
themselves you cannot have a free
gluon or free quark
so let's look at this running a little
bit more so we have this
annoying alpha s of a function of q
square
you can get rid of this actually by
redefining the parameter here
and using this lambda parameter or
lambda qcd as it's oft called
or lambda color as it's called here
under c when we do this we can rewrite
the equations
so we find that there is no dependency
anymore of the scale involved and we
don't have to find this fixed point
we still have the dependency of 11n
minus 2f and then this log dependency of
on q
square over this specific scale
so the strength of the coupling is with
this definition defined for any value of
q
square finding this lambda qt is kind of
complicated because
if you go to very low q square
calculations and experiments cannot be
easily be compared anymore
so we find that lambda qcd is in the
order of 100 to 500 mb okay
um here are experimental measurements so
alpha the
strength of the strong interaction have
been measured in many experiments
you can measure this for example in the
case of tau leptons where there's hot
ones being produced and therefore you
have sensitivity
to alpha s you can use bound states
um deep inelastic scattering experiments
and pdfs fits can be used in order to
constrain
[Music]
alpha s we can use e plus minus physics
and look at the distribution of jets we
saw that the
additional radiation of a chlorine is
sensitive to the
to this vertex of a quark radiating a
plun
and therefore to the strength of the of
qcd
um you find that those experiments are
all in reasonable agreement this
this line here indicates now the average
value at a specific
value specific scale and typically when
people compare measurements they use the
scale of the
z boson mass about 90 gb in order to
compare
the values you can see here the running
of alpha s
the running of the strong coupling
assumption of q and you see
the behavior of asymptotic freedom
meaning that the coupling becomes small
at very large value of
q and very large in the small values of
content
all right so that's it for asymptotic
freedom and the running of alpha s
we have a little bit more of a
discussion in qcd before we enter the
next chapter